let's read this first story from abc 13
wham
project veritas says it caught cnn
staffer
admitting network pushed anti-trump
propaganda
this is an abc affiliate reporting this
which if if local news outlets are
picking up project veritas the story is
pretty big
they say veritas unveiled a video
tuesday that says that the group says is
of a cnn staffer describing how the
network worked to show
then presidential candidate joe biden in
a favorable light during the 2020
campaign
the undercover video captured a man the
self-proclaimed conservative watchdog
group identified
as cnn technical director charlie
chester i'm not sure
veritas has ever self-proclaimed to be
conservative watchdogs but i digress
saying he decided to work with the
network because it focused on removing
former president donald trump chester
also credited cnn as a critical tool in
electing biden
quote look what we did we got we cnn got
trump out i am 100
going to say it and i 100 believe that
if it wasn't for cnn i don't know that
trump would have got voted out
i came to cnn because i wanted to be a
part of that the man said in one portion
of the video
chester was speaking to someone off
camera at undisclosed locations
he was targeted through the dating app
tinder according to mediaite
that is impressive work from project
veritas
how do they do that tinder is random it
shows you a person
so they have they so james o'keefe has
got young women like
swiping right on these dudes like just
scouring tinder looking for someone
saying i work at cnn boom
well that's a foreign intelligence way
you know you you ever if you just do
mass you know spread and then you can
target it down
as i find the person i'm impressed if
they if they really did use tinder to
get access to these these guys that
means veritas does
more substantive investigative work than
i realized yeah good tradecraft
or could have been a girl that just met
some dude was like oh you work for cnn
oh i got to get in touch with project
veritas about things
i gotta say you know if they're
reporting that i really believe it
because you have to wonder
how it is they consistently get access
to some of these people they're not just
like
walking into places and being like hi
tell me all your secrets
going on a date with some dude and
having him spill the beans now i will
say you got to be careful about one
thing
could this guy be hamming it up because
he's trying to get laid
well definitely for sure yes of course
is is she like i hate trouble because i
hate trump too yeah in fact
yeah and then she's like yeah yeah like
would it be cool like cnn helped
help get him out oh yeah cnn definitely
did that i did that that's why i'm here
right back to my place yeah that's
almost why we need the kind of body
camera right with the police officer
before
they pull up yeah right do you want the
totality of the circumstances but
you know what though i will i will say
um there there was one
undercover video that project veritas
got with a guy i'm not gonna name
that i knew and they had a young woman
talking to this guy
and the guy was saying all this stuff
about what he could do at the new york
times or whatever
and i'm like dude he is ham ended up he
is trying to impress this lady
he's talking smack and i'll say it right
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna chill for
veritas in every circumstance i'll
criticize him if
i see some some reason to do it but this
is different
this is a news this is someone who's
working for a cnn a technical director
who has no problem telling members of
the public be it is he lying to this
young woman about what cnn does
he's he's confident enough for whatever
reason to say
cnn produces fear we propagandize
and our goal was political i said it
that's it
and i i do think one of the challenges
here though for cnn and
of course it applies to other outlets is
that you know
on one side you do have we saw in the
campaign
obviously um very anti-trump coverage
very pro-biden
um and the other side you know certainly
some of their foreign policy
correspondents
uh kylie atkins you know jim schudo who
i think has
sort of moved more in the opinion side
you know do really good
reporting so it's a it it's a challenge
for them in a sense right that they
that this you know because this is not
great for their
you know credibility well the outlets
and it's sort of unfair on there in a
sense i don't think they care
i think you know you turn on reliable
sources today and what's oliver darcy
and brian sister talk stealth were
talking about
who's the right wing boogeyman today i
jokingly you know i'll tweet it brian
selter
that he's the host of the fox news
review show right because you turn on
sunday morning with cnn and it's brian
brian styles are telling you what fox
news is talking about i'm like what is
this
how is this in any way news about the
media environment tucker carlson said
something offensive
and i'm like okay what's going on with
the me are there layoffs
is the business growing what are
journalists doing no it's just basically
cnn's like hey we can make money because
people don't like fox news
and there you go in a sense though you
know brian stelter's media show it's
not so much like how how he curts on fox
it's sort of i think more become
kind of laura ingram right or sean
hannity that it's a more overtly opinion
show
yeah that that's presenting itself as a
media show absolutely absolutely and
and and i'll say that you know with
respect he's allowed to do that right
if he wants to be an opinion show if he
wants to be the sunday morning version
of hannity for the left or whatever
right
the only problem is you know when sean
hannity rags on the liberal media
there's many different liberal medias to
rag on
right the fox news is almost one of a
kind i mean for cable news it basically
is
when me when reliable sources you know
cnn just talks about fox news all day
every day i'm like
i i'm just i'm not i don't see the
urgency here man
you know what i mean it's one channel i
know they got a big viewership but when
you combine cbs abc nbc
msnbc hln cnn etc i mean we're looking
at 30 40 50 million views or whatever
and then fox news they're huge you know
three million views
they're rivaling you know rachel maddow
and they're they're
bouncing back and forth between cnn and
the rate beating cnn the ratings
but you combine all of these media
outlets and their bias fox news doesn't
really
reach that level so it's like cnn doing
that show is
really weird in my opinion but more to
the point
cnn's coverage has been just just just
absolutely awful along with many of
these other outlets
now we're hearing this guy say all this
stuff i'm just kind of like you know
i have something i call the cnn
challenge i did call the cnn challenge
you can't really do it anymore because
trump's not president
but i would i'm somebody who watches the
news and i would turn out
i used to watch cnn i used to leave cnn
running in the background so i'd have
some like breaking news
you know here's what's happening and
then just one day i'm like are they
talking about trump again
so i switched to fox news and they're
like protests erupt in iran
you know tehran you know protesters in
tehran are doing and i'm like wow this
is big
and then i switch back to cnn like but
trump you need to understand about trump
and i'm like okay
so i did it several times one point fox
news is like hong kong protests to
europe
china's moving in turn to cnn now donald
trump is
i even turned to cnn to fox news once
and like a big winter storm is headed
our way everyone you need to buckle down
turn to cnn oh donald trump
and so i just called it the trump
challenge because that's basically what
they were you know their bread and
butter
now take all of that information and
someone made a really interesting point
with this cnn cnn technical director
stating in numerous
videos we were activists we were trying
to get the president out the goal was
political we produced propaganda
some people have said that fulfills the
actual malice standard
now allowing donald trump to sue cnn for
defamation
because you have a cnn staffer a
director on the record saying
yeah we're full of it you know can you
use this guy's
is it testimony is this considered what
is it can you use this guy's statements
as like
in a court of law i don't know i'm not a
lawyer no that
he i mean they would have to get him
test i i don't think there's any chance
of that the actual malice standard
you know new york times who solomon
which is the case
especially the federal courts uh the
judiciary in terms of the case on this
has been very
predisposed uh towards deference towards
media speech and i think that's the way
to go and i just
for them they would have to show number
one that was representative
of cnn uh and of who spoke in the first
place exactly did he have the authority
as an agency to to say that and who and
and the individual who reported say
donald trump you know
you know punched a goat or something
right was it the same person
right did that person genuinely believe
they're telling the truth so it's not so
kind and dry
but i actually i i i agree with i agree
to assert
i agree to a certain degree that
protecting speech for the media is
important
in that sometimes there is a legitimate
attempt at reporting news
you make a mistake and if we sued every
time someone got something wrong
there wouldn't be news outlets right
news outlets should correct and that
i guess that was the the the intent it
was like well you know they can just
correct the record but there's no
obligation to do it that's problem
number one if cnn writes fake news
and donald trump says please correct
this they can say
no then you know trump or somebody will
file a defamation suit
and the judge will say anti-slap you're
dismissed get out
so how do you correct the record when
these news outlets are lying and you
can't break through that that
you know actual male standard that
barrier well i i think the ultimate
correction point you would hope and and
certainly i believe it is is that
you know credibility is lost right that
you would the consumer ultimately
gets to decide what they want with news
right you have people watching this show
you have people watching cnn whatever
their reasons you have
people reading across the gamut of news
and commentary
and that ultimately we would hope uh
that that people decide actually when
they see stuff coming out and a lack of
responsibility right people are willing
to forgive mistakes
uh that perhaps it's not the place for
them to that's that's the inverse though
if cnn admits they were wrong they lose
credibility well they lose credibility
with their most loyal base but i think
if if they don't admit they're wrong
then the saliency of the fact well that
that i think i think you know people are
talking about i mean project veritas
right that it's out there i i agree with
you
you note earlier that i i think is
absolutely true the
um the fact that fox news is in its own
at least in cable news kind of oddness
and we see this right with newsmax
trying to break in there
and struggling to get on and we saw
actually you know it and it's it's
something
there's going to be a great battle in
the uk coming up with a couple of new
uh networks trying to break in there and
some of the lobbying already the bbc
they don't want that competition in
there
canada with um the sun news network that
wasn't able
to be viable because it wasn't able to
get on you know
providers yeah and and so yeah
it's a double-edged sword if if if you
can't force them to correct
we have a very serious problem because
then there's incentive to lie
they make money on the lie if if they
write a fake news story
they could be sitting there thinking
like look the worst case scenario is we
try to rewrite a story saying donald
trump punches a you know baby goat
we're gonna get 10 million views we're
gonna make you know
hundreds of thousands of dollars and if
we have to track tomorrow it's no big
deal
because you know what they make money on
their attraction as well yeah
and you know i think a broader challenge
there is that i used to think one of the
great solutions to this is
we have google news right that you can
read around and then i realized well
uh google news seems to be providing
some news outlets more equal than others
you know it's borrowed from orwell and
and it's really i mean it's true
you know i don't know oh yeah and i
don't know why uh well i have
my suspicions that there's an inherent
bias i actually emailed google about
this and they said
no no no our algorithms prevent that
from ever happening
okay i i'm not convinced that that might
be the case so
you know if as you say right people need
to be able to not only
access the news but know that
counterpoint exists and
people are busy right yes right so so
the problem i see is this
you hire a plumber you know when the
plumber doesn't fix your toilet
right so you're like hey buddy i need
you to come in and fix the toilet he
comes in and says your toilet's all
fixed and you're like alright you flush
it and then the water spills out you're
like it's not fixed
right i can see it's broken right within
with news you're hoping that what
they're telling you is the truth
after they come out and they say here's
your official news report on the middle
east
go ahead and read it you're like i i'm
assuming it's true
i just cross my fingers and hope the guy
i hired to do the job is telling me the
truth
and often they're not they they do
clever tricks sometimes
it's the truth but you omit half the
information the story is very different
for instance
when trump the trump slump hit and the
ratings dropped
newsmax ratings go down cnn ratings go
down what a cnn report
newsmax ratings collapse but if they
told you the truth
everyone's ratings went down the reality
was people
in general are just tired of news by
framing it only as newsmax they make it
seem
like trump's followers are losing faith
or they're not interested
in reality had nothing to do with it
right that's just the manipulation it's
the framing technique
right no i mean it's it is and and you
know i do think though if if we look at
um the ability of um
especially the younger generation to
access you know the astuteness with
which they are dealing with technology
um uh and looking for
you know more creative even rebellious
um kind of outlooks
that dynamic um is only going to
continue to grow and i know that sounds
kind of basic and shallow and sort of
almost kind of kind of corporatist and
it's simplicity but it
if you look at foreign locales for
example the
the degree to which for example
clubhouse is performing you know a
massive challenge to china
yeah that the census this industrial you
know ten
hundreds of thousands of people employed
to constrain flows of information
they can't because then there's a sub
club house and then there's you know
someone goes across and uses a cutout
isp and
you know and and certainly that that's
what we've been doing but the us was
doing in iran i think the
administration has actually cut it off
the cia program but
um we were allowing iranians to
communicate
we were we were providing them with um
independent satellite
kind of prov you know internet as i
understand it yeah it's part of it it's
part of
it's part of a community it's part of a
cover action program a trump
administration set up
i mean that seems like a good thing yeah
helping people communicate with each
other
yeah human rights as well right yeah
trump supposedly didn't like that so
much but well biden must not be for
human rights i suppose
right well yeah i'm starting to have a
hard time differentiating between
the onion and cnn and random youtuber
spouting who he hates
and and loves like it's it's all
becoming this this crap hole
like just just opinion and like is it
even far
is it farce i can't even tell you know
what the funny thing is the babylon b
is at this point i'm i'm gonna wag my
finger they're not satire anymore you
know why
because they're actually reporting the
truth
but facetiously so they'll say something
like
um what what what i think that i think
it was the babylonian put this out they
say
um after securing peace in the middle
east the u.s announces they'll withdraw
from afghanistan
because joe biden announced we're going
to be withdrawing from afghanistan in
september hey i'm all for that thank you
joe biden
i mean it all right no i think he's
gonna just throw him right back into
syria so
you know we got to make sure we're going
to stay vigilant on this one but i do
think it's funny when babylon b
reports a story that it is satire
they're making fun of it but it's like
basically the truth but snarky
so that's like we're we're in such a
world of absurdity
that even now i mean they're they're the
look the biden administration is right
for parity especially right now
kyle kashuv tweeted i was told by so
many people that
if we voted for joe biden everything
would come back to normal and the
violence would stop you know so so where
where are we at guys the riots are
kicking back up everything's getting
worse
it is a world of parody man i do i do
think still
and of course my accent would suggest
buyers hit but i'm trying to
you know be objective bbc news their
website
um i think it's still very good there is
of course
bias um the analytical when they have
some of the reporters doing their
analysis i think the bias comes through
the more yeah but the
basic nuts and bolts reporting on there
and the ability to kind of go in
different places
a lot of that is informed by some of the
world service stuff they do
um and there are actually pretty good
structured checks and balances at bbc
and i i complained about a piece
um their russian bbc news wrote about me
about
an article i'd written a couple years
ago and you know they have a two week
um you know respond to complaints goes
through a process
so of course the counterpoint to that is
well that is being paid for by
um you know the uh tv license fee which
everyone in the uk has to pay so there's
a tax you know so
so this is not you know bbc is pretty
good um
but you've got to read around exactly
you've got to read around because which
is sad you know
it's you know pretty good doesn't mean
you can just trust every single thing
you're going to read from from them or
from anybody
so you know when it comes to sources
they have a lot of dry articles that's a
good thing
right when you read the news and it's
like you know donald trump said today
that he was planning on putting tariffs
on this country
joe biden responded you know blah blah
blah and that's just it's just that
you're like okay that's that's probably
just you know good right
it's when they start talking about the
far right and
you know yeah it's like opinion possible
right the definition here's the
important point about the times v
sullivan thing
that project veritas has just won and
may set precedent for years to come
they you i'm sure you're familiar
they're showing the new york times you
heard about that yes
well they got past the motion to dismiss
which is huge i think james said
only eight times in the past you know 80
years or whatever has the has emotion to
dismiss been
have people got past that and what the
judge basically said is that
you know well hold on the new york times
said these statements about
project veritas being deceptive are
unverifiable opinion and thus are not
actionable and so the judge responded
okay well
if that was the case then i guess a
fact-based news article or at least one
purporting to be would have to inform
its readers this is an opinion
not a certain opinion as a fact in which
case i guess he's basically saying
if you say this article i'm about to
read to you is 100
fact ian is a deceiver and a liar then
the assumption is i'm saying statements
of fact in a newspaper
yeah i just think when we get to the
supreme court i i i take the point that
the case law is trying i think the
judges are trying to get a little bit
more
nuance on this and when it gets to the
supreme court that i think it's probably
going to be
you know eight to one uh in favor in the
new york times that
do you think so because i think the
judiciary and and i really i ultimately
i think it's the right course uh
uh that they should be allowed maximum
no that maximal speech
uh for all this cost lies included uh
is advantageous over um
not so much restricted speech but the
chilling of speech i think that is the
great
concern in jurisprudence and really
foundational actually to the united
states i mean and you look at how
the contrast in english defamation law
for example which is why
you know we were talking earlier i think
why we have the qatar world cup it's a
very good case to be made for that that
the lawyers the sunday times
uh didn't report as early as they could
have on the the bribery
um and you know certainly that
it's interesting for example how much uh
american
journalists will get um letters from
you know english london pr or legal
firms saying
this is uh highly defamatory take it
down no
no no i know that's the you know who
would maybe be great as it is and it's a
lot of lies and they get well
i i don't think it is i think when
you're talking about russian organized
crime bosses who
like to kill people and it doesn't get
reported in the british media because
they have a lot of money it'll take you
to court it's good that
you know i'm writing about that i
couldn't do that in england that matters
that stuff
the problem then is that they literally
just make things up activists are
dominating these newsrooms and when
you know the the idea works when you
have a newsroom that's filled with
people of
good moral standing you'll have a few
bad people trying to lie but when
activists take over a newsroom like they
did in the new york times and they did
several employees have already resigned
or been forced out or written letters
about it
then there's going to be like awesome
now we're going to use times v sullivan
to say whatever we want about whoever we
want there is nothing they can do about
it but then they literally come out and
say
the new york times said in their defense
our our news article which is purporting
to be statements of fact are actually
unverifiable opinion
and the average reader doesn't know that
you know i i guess i i have more
confidence in the the average reader in
terms of being more discriminated i
think
certainly again this this generational
shift i mean you look at you know
your viewership uh the hill saga and
jetty and crystal ball show
um you know these new form media places
are just growing exponentially
and you know you got to think that that
that some of these people
are um even if they're not necessarily
abandoning
you know they're still reading the new
york times uh they're reading around
more or viewing around more
right and and so you know i i do think
again
at some point you're always going to
have those people who want to hear what
they want to hear um
but you're also going to have i think a
lot of people who um
get slightly frustrated with limited
time right they want to be informed you
know
investigative journalism that really
stands up is still the best way to
generate traffic
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you